When I try to start my programs on my rife machine recently, I get a screen that says I'm not connected.
When I x out of that screen, it gives me the screen that I need to select my desired program.
Question, why is this change suddenly? Maybe I'm rushing the selection process?
don't want to harm the machine. So you have the true rife machine, I believe. So
these are some of the issues that we've had with true rife updating things. So you'd want to
I'd want to know what version you're running, whether it's version six or version six point four to be
exact. And then what we'd really have to walk you through that. So you'll probably have to call
the clinic and schedule the time to talk to Dustin. And he could, you know, what he's what you're
on the phone with him, make sure you're at the rife computer. It's plugged in and everything. And you
could kind of walk through the screen selection that you would see that he could help you with it.
Is it getting to the point? My question to me is he getting to the point where it's actually running
the program. If it is, it may be some update that they did that's about that's popping up.
Yeah, that's that's my complaint with the new owners with true rife. They are
owners that are, you know, concerned about making money in business, not concerned about
caring for patients like Mike used to be where he was more centered around doing everything. What's
going to help his client base, even though he didn't, he wasn't a doctor. He wanted to the best care
for his clients where the new owners are kind of taking shortcuts. So I don't know if that,
if you updated your programs lightly or something like that. So the best thing to do would be
just to call and schedule a time with Dustin probably early next week.